Now, I'd like to ask you about random walks.
These are really interesting things that show up in everything from finance to physics,
but amazingly they're the exact same thing you learned about when you learned about
when you learned how to manipulate normal distributions.
Let's assume we have some object--it could be me,
it could be a point, it could be an insect,
it could be a particle in a fluid--
sitting right here at position 0.
Now, let's assume that it moves every second in a normally distributed way.
Its movement has a mean of 0 and a standard deviation of 1.
Note that in this case the variance and the standard deviation are actually the same
since they're both 1.
What I'd like to ask you is after 1 second tell me what the mean
and standard deviation of the object's position is.
Please tell me the object's mean position and the variance of that position.